I've always got a lot more to do than I
have time to not necessarily just work
that has to be done but things I want to
see things I want to learn about
didn't find any caribou out there but I
was lucky enough to get a porcupine
I've eaten muskrats I've eaten squirrels
but if I'm gonna eat a rodent there's
nothing better than a porcupine because
of this five fats hard to come by a lot
of animals out here really lean but this
porcupine as you can see he's got a good
layer of fat on him fat has more
calories than protein or carbohydrate
and you need a lot of calories stay warm
takes energy and that's why porcupine is
a special food for me out here look at
that I got front leg I got a back leg
and plenty of fat to go with that meat
that's some having for dinner tonight
porcupine everybody has to decide how
they want to live where they want to get
their food it's just the way I choose to
do it because I enjoy it I enjoy living
out here enjoy the lifestyle feel more
connected to my surroundings I don't
think this is for everybody but I think
unfortunately there are a lot of people
that aren't doing what they love to do
and that's too bad to let life go by and
not do what you really want to do if you
really want to do something you want to
get out and do it this is what I want to
do so this is what I did
I bet it's just about done oh yeah that
looks delicious
look at that porcupine mmm does that
smell good look at that full moon one
night to eat out ate mostly moose and
then caribou comes next but once a while
I come across something like a porcupine
get a little variety
that's porcupine fat it's good stuff mmm
hmm that's the best part right there it
is a little spruce II he's been feeding
on spruce bark lately connect me the
forest right here food tastes a little
bit like the area